ライフワークって何でしょうか？だからテーマを発表しましたからね
もう全部完了しなきゃ私はちょっと気が済まないんですね
ライフワークの勘違い
まあ読むだけにします
これ一番難しいんですけど
このセクションは ライフワークの世間論
何でした？これは傑作を生み出すことですかね
あるいは学者の一生の研究成果
ノーベル賞 自然と動物の写真を撮ること
よくやってますから みんなライフワーク
あるいは会社の仕事 趣味
自分に我を忘れて集中できる何かを
これでしょう 世界で言ってるライフワーク
これが世間が考えるライフワークです
これ勘違い 以上のことは
何をやっても次の世代は無視するんです
おじいさんがいっぱい写真撮って撮って撮って
10万も100万ぐらい撮っても
よくできたもの それで死んじゃったら全部潰れる
ライフワーク 生涯にわたる研究の成果を発表しても
次の世代の若者にいとも簡単に交代されるんです
だから 大教授がずっと研究していたら
あの あれ 何でしたっけ？日本の方は
あの えっとえっとえっと
あの なんとかクラゲをね
もう 100万匹やらもう殺して殺して殺して
で ちょっと輝く液体タンパク質を見つけたんですけど
もうはるかにそこら辺は若者たちがもう進んでやっているんです
だから あの教授はまあどこか大学で
まあなんとか言って控えめで生活するしかないんです
若者には敵わないんです
だから結局そこまで研究して研究成果出すでしょ
学生がすぐそこから学ぶんだから
自分の学生が 弟子がそこから学んで自分の論文を発表するでしょ
先生の一生がこの若者の 2年の研究でパーになっちゃうんです
そこでその人はまた一生何か研究テーマにハマって一生やっちゃいますけど
自分たちの生徒たちにまたやられちゃう
やられるんじゃなくて
もう交代されたんですね
だからそういうのはライフワークって面白くないんですよ
世界に残る作品などはあるが
今亡き作家には何の影響も恵みもないんですよ
時々あるでしょ まあもうね
いろんな立派な絵画とかね
厳重に守って でも 描いた人にとってはね
かわいそうで 食べるものもろくになくて
苦しんで生きてただけでしょう
音楽家にしたら ベートーベンやらいろいろね
本当にもう苦しんでたんですけど
この画家たちがもう食べるものがなくて
人の恵みで何かいただいて食べるぐらいでしたからね
それで絵を描いて 今は億億単位で
だからなんだこれって
おじいさんの大事なコレクションの孫たちは安値で売って遊ぶ金にするんだからね
それがライフワークでしょうかね
世尊の説法のように 後の人々の役に立つ本格的なライフワークも確かにあるんです
お釈迦様のお話はライフワークです
死ぬ直前 瞬間まで喋っていたんです
本当のライフワーク やがて喋れなくなっちゃったんです
そこでまたもう 2 3 分で涅槃に上がったんです
そこまで説法していたんです
未だに残っているだけではなくて
未だにも役に立つ 未だにも機能する
ゴミ扱いはできん ゴミ扱いしようとしたら本人がゴミになるだけ
ブッダの教えは輝いている
だからそれがライフワーク
遺跡などはすでに壊れていて使うことができないので
ライフワークではありませんよ
いろんな遺跡あるでしょ？なんでしたっけ？あのピラミッドやらね
日本でもたくさんあるでしょうに
当時の人々のライフワークでしたとかね
言ったっても 今は役に立ちませんよ
全部壊れているし だから保存しているだけ
こっちは歩くなよとかね
もういろいろロープを張って
また 偉大なる業績を残すとは
稀な人間にしかできないことも事実でしょう
こういう風にも 偉大なる業績を残すということは稀な人なんですよ
だからみんなにライフワークできるんですかね
それだったら一人一人にできるライフワークがあるはずです
ライフワークっていうのは一人一人にできるはずなんです
それが本物のライフワークなんです
輪廻転生を繰り返しながら生きることは
そのこの心が回転し続けていることです
我々は一人一人がモーツァルトであろうか
ベートーヴェンであろうか
モネであろうか 輪廻転生しているんですよ
だから それ心が回転しているんですね
仮に自分自分のものと言えるのは
そのこの心の働きです
仮に言えるんです 私のもの
心の働きです 自分自分というのは心のことなんです
それも仮ですけどね しかし
その心が無知で貪瞋痴で罪で汚れているのです
長い長い輪廻転生させているこの心がずっと汚れているんです
汚れた心で生きることも苦しいんです
苦労に苦労を重ねて一生せやして
何かをしても 次の世代はそれをゴミ扱いします
貧困で生まれて億万長者になって死んでも
財産は他人のもので 自分には精神貧困のままで他界するのです
で 生きている場合は億万長者になったんだけど
死ぬ時はまた貧困なんです
精神貧困 このような無駄なことをライフワークにするのはよろしいでしょうか？と
だから そんなライフワークになりません
貧困で死んでいいんですかね
精神的に ですから 誰にでもできるライフワークはあります
この汚れた心を何としてでも清らかにすること
皆にできるライフワークです
俺も断言でき それ以外ないんですよ
死ぬ間際までやることがあるんです
だって ちょっとしたことで心汚れますよ
だからずっと死ぬ間際までライフワークは残っています
また その成果は自分のもので
自分が持っていくんです
心清らかにすれば 残された人々も故人を敬うんです
心清らかにしたならば
おじいさんは敬われますよ
写真たくさん置いておいたっても
意味がないんです 輪廻をしても
次から次へと幸福になるんです
心清らかにすると えーと
職業に励んでいる時も
仕事をしている時も 旅行に出る時も
旅に出る時も 家族と楽しんでいる時も
病で悩んでいる時も 貪瞋痴を制御することに励むのです
何やってもいいんです
何もやりながら 貪瞋痴だけは起こらないようにと気をつけるのです
だからライフワークですよ
仕事をしているはいるんだ
心は汚さないようにと気をつけなくちゃいけない
で 職業仕事を二つでしょ
それで旅に出るのはいいんだけど
旅に出たっても心は汚れないようにということで
ライフワークです はい
人生そのものを心清らかにする行為に変えるんです
老人になるまで汚れた心で良い
老年だから心は汚れても良いなどの理屈は成り立たないんです
年取るまで若いんだからね
まあいい加減に生活したらいいと言えませんよ
今は老人だから まあわがままでできなく汚い心でいいとはないでしょうに
汚れた心で生きる時間は不幸を築く時間なのです
だから汚れた心で十分いたら
10 分間不幸を築いたことになるのです
これ ライフワークにならないでしょう
不幸を築くこと だから不幸を築くことだから
やっぱり心清らかにすること以外は何もないんです
もしも心が二度と汚れないようにすることができれば
それは生きることを乗り越えたことです
それで話は終わります
で 二度と汚れない状況を作れば
もうライフワークは完了
だから僕のライフワークはちょっと長いんです
輪廻転生する羽目にもなりますしね
まあとにかく あの ずっと一生何やってもいいんですよ
何やってもいいんだけど
心だけは汚れないようにする
だから私は言ったでしょ
商売やることもできますよ
欲でやるんじゃなくて
自分の義務であって 権利であって
収入はいなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それぐらいの気持ちでやれば
もう結構立派でしょうに
はい それで本当に時間たくさんなくなりましたから
成功に達したことです
それで完全に心清らかにすることができたならば
はい 終わりです はい 結構時間はなくなりましたけど
はい そういうことで あの
仏教っていうのは難しいんですよ
もうまあいい いい職業なんとかやってないかというと
すごいシンプルに考えますけどね
皆様方というか 世間がね
真理を知らなすぎだからね
結果 厳しくする道を選ぶちゃいけないんですよ
仏教を学んだだけで結構頭が良くなりますよ
だからまあ本当のところ
私はちょこちょこっともうというのはよく作ったもんですけど
だから仏教を学んでるんだからね
かなり今日ね まあ作れます
で そこを書きながらも
今回は本当にいい加減だらしないな
手抜きばっかりやと自分でも悩みながら
しかし内容を見てみると結構入ってます
私は書きたいものってまだ書いたらどうなるんですかね
大変なことになるんです
頭が良くなりますから
一生懸命仏教を学んでください
ちょっと例え苦しむたっても
これは心清らかになります
これ以上話す必要はないので
それで話を終了したいと思います
どうもありがとうございます
いろいろ質問とかありますか？はいはい
トラブルがあった中 ごほうびありがとうございました
あの 一つだけ質問させていただきます
あの生命は業を相続する
それと あの生命は心によって輪廻転生するということでありますけれども
そうするとですね 心とその業の関係といいますか
心のエネルギーですね
心のエネルギーが業  心って別なものじゃないんで
全部もう同じものなんです
はい 他は何かございますかね
はいはい こちらお願いします
身体障害者って人は結構いるわけですけど
手足がなかったり 目が見えなかったり
あるいはすごいあの難病という 10万人に一人とか
100万人に一人とか
そういうすごい難病にかかってる人とか
他人の助けがないと一人で生きることができないという人もいるわけですよね
そういう人はどういうふうに
まあ職業はまずできないだろうけど
仕事とか で どういうふうにそういう手足がない人とか
目が見えない 耳が聞こえない
喋れないとか あるいはすごい難病にかかっている人はに対しての仕事
仕事はどうあるべきか
少しご説明をお願いいたします
それってそんなに大きな問題じゃないでしょ
たくさんいるって言ったらそんなにたくさんいませんよ
難病にかかってもうどうにもならない
もうベッドの上にしか動かないって人っていうのはものすごく稀ですよ
だからまあ その場合は明確に助けてあげなくちゃいけないだけのことでしょうね
しかし この障害なんかは別にどうったことないんです
目が見えないぐらいで
耳が聞こえないぐらいで
結構立派に生きてられますよ
だってもう両手もなくても
もういろんな筋肉 なんだらかんたらっていろいろありますね
収縮ですごく痛くなる部位とかね
それで足でなんとか筆を取って絵を描いたりすると
これまた見事に描くんだから
だからまあ これ結構人気あったらしいですね
まあそれなりにみんな買ったりもするし
他も五体満足の人は描くのは描くの誰も買ってくれないしね
だから 例えばスティービー・ワンダーが障害者ですかね
スティービー・ワンダー
それ誰です？ え？ 目が見えないアメリカの歌手
カタカナにすれば知ってると思います
その人は知りません  あれと傲慢長者ですけど
歌って 目が見えないんです
だからあの そんなの大げさな問題じゃないんです
本当に重度の場合は これはその人を助けることは我々の仕事義務になるんですね
それで それでもそういう人々はそれなりにニコッと笑ったりとかね
してますから それは十分です
それも仕事になるんです
仕事です あれで結構疲れが取れますからね
なんかそこある男の人なんですけど
ある日電車で見て やっぱりあの人的障害なんですね
体はその分すごいでっかいんです
ものすごい背が高くて
で見たら これ知的障害の子だなと思ったんで
なんのことなく私みたいに面白がっちゃって頭触ったり
あの お父さん見て お父さんどうすることもできなくて
で 私は顔見てニコッと笑って
で どうとか だから体でっかくても
私より 1.5倍ぐらいあったんですけど
大男でしたけど やっぱりまだ子供なんですね
成長しないんですね だからその部分とかね
背中叩いたりとか 向こうも手をぎゅっと握ったりとか
で また頭を毛がないんだから
これ楽しかったんですよ
怖いともなんともなくて
だからそうやってもう
何の遠慮もなく 誰ともやりたいことをやるっていうことは一つのいい仕事ですよ
だから  我々は期待するのは我々けしからんだけであって
でも人々はなんとかしていますよ
あまり大きな問題にせไม่ต้อง
はい 恐ろしい マイクもらってください
医療の仕事についている人で
一生懸命仕事を真面目にやっていても
本人も予期しない ちょっとしたミスで人が解雇されて具合が悪くなって
ひどい時には死んだりとかいうことが
まああるんですけども
そういう時には それでまあそのミスをしてしまった人とか
すごく落ち込んで まあ仕事を辞めるっていうことを言う人は多いんですけども
そういう人に対してどういうふうに職業についてアドバイスしていただければいいですか
アドバイスしたって このトンチンチの塊の社会には意味がないでしょうに
人を馬鹿にして貶すことしか能がないんだからね
もう医者にしたっても
クタクタいじめられていじめられて
もうもう仕事できん状態じゃないし
そこでちょっとでも失敗したら
まあだったら初めから全部医者たちを追い出せばいいでしょうに
こんな何でも三国かと思う
本は知らないしね どちらでも
だからそういう問題ばっかりなんですよ
うん だから医者のことはそれなりに感謝の気持ちでよく頑張ってるんだっていうね
あれば向こうはストレスはないんでしょうね
それだったら で しかし
医者が失敗するのはね
看護師さんが失敗するのはとんでもないもってのほかですけどね
何の大学勉強したんですかね
だからまあ それが失敗したいんだから失敗してるわけじゃないんです
でしょ ストレス溜まってるんです
管理厳しくて 仕切り厳しくて
もう動かないんですよ
医者の言うのは 例えば我々は治療を受けて 2万円払っても
実際医者に行くのはまあ 500円とか 700円とか
あのお金が全部あの余計などうでもいい管理にかかってしまうんです
だからもうちょっとストレスなく穏やかで仕事をした方がミスは起こらないと
ミスは起こってはならないことですから
大体起こらないんですよ
もう落ち着いて 治療できればね
うーん だから落ち着いていることって大事なんですよ
それで興奮したり 疲れたなとかっていうと
もう怒りが出てくるんですね
大体医者の心に怒りが入るんですよ
医療関係の場合は結構入ります
怒りが猛毒で次失敗する
だから特に医療関係の人は結構精神的な修行をするためにした方がいいと思います
調子に乗るんじゃなくて
自分はもう怒りやすい
疲れやすい 頑張っても感謝してくれないし
医者を訴えることしか考えていないしね
無邪心ですよ それでもやってますからね
立派なもんですよ だから医療関係の方々は
このかなり心を落ち着いてもらって
心を明るくする 心の修行をつけた方がいいと思いますよ
それは医学の一環としてやった方がいいと思います
大学でも学ぶべきです
落ち着いている分で 何やってもニコッと笑って許すんでやった方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
そうすると結構そういうのはなくなります
医療ミスなどは 自分の子でも最近なんかワクチン
学校でね 子供たちルベッラっていうワクチンですけどね
で 子供一人が死んじゃったんです
で また何人か子供たちがちょっと調子が悪くなったんですけど
それはもうただ怖くなっただけ
やってることで で そうするとすぐたちまち調べたんです
で 専門家のグループに行って
で ただ このお母さんがこの自分の子供がこのあれでアレルギーですよと
まあこういうこういうアレルギーありますから
大変厳しいんだから そこを考えてくださいと
このワクチンの出す日なんです
学校だからもう強引にまとめて出させてやっちゃいますからね
親の気持ちなんて聞くこと
あの医者かやった人が
医療関係の人はもう全然見てもないみたいですね
この母親の手紙を 母親もすごい丁寧にワクチンやめてくださいと書いてないんですよ
うちの子にはこういうこういう食べ物は全く食べられませんと
まあ大体誰にでもあるあれだからね
牛乳系のものは全く口に入らないと
また食べ物の中でこれこれを食べたら大変なことになりますよと
ですから この問題は適切に考えてくださいと書いてあったんです
立派な母親ですよ うちの子にはワクチンさせないでくださいではないんです
だってそれ向こうの仕事でしょ
このワクチンはどんなどんな症状を起こすのか
どんなどんなというと
それはもちろん仕事でしょ
これ見ようともしないでやっちゃって死んじゃって
まあどうなるかわからない
だからちょっとした傲慢というか
見えというか わからない状況は
なんでそれ読まなかったっていうことをね
そういう傲慢な態度で失敗したら
医者免許を取り上げたり
逮捕されたりするのは
それはしょうがないんです
で そうではなく 医療ミスっていうのはね
起こらないんですよ すごく落ち着いている
私はそれよくわかっていて
もうちょっと態度でさっさと自分が冗談言ったり
いろんなことしたりしてすごい落ち着いてもらうんです
だってあの血液検査に行ったって
もうこれ 2回刺したら嫌だから
あれは あまり血管見えないね
一回この血取りますって言ったら
本人がこのバンドを貼って見ているんだけど
血管が見えてこないんですね
だから私は突然 私は本当は持ってきたと思っていたのに
おそらく忘れてるかもしれませんけど
とんでもなく本人なんとかびっくりしちゃって
変なこと言うんだからね
さっさと来たんだから忘れたかもしれませんだからと言ったんです
結果 言ったらすぐ気分良くなっちゃって
で そんなこと冗談でしょうし
で もう何回も何回も毎日やっていることだから
もう慣れたもんでしょ
ですから 推測でさっと針を刺したんですよ
肉とあたり 本人もびっくり
普通は血管ちょこちょこっと見て刺すんだから
もう見えないんです 私の手で
で 推測で当たったらぴったし当たりで
あ 持ってきているんだ
忘れてないんだというんで
本人も自信 本人にも自信つきましたということで
それで自分もそれなりにサービスはしているんです
精神的に だから なんで私はそういう瞬間にアホなことをするのかというと
やっぱり向こうは人間でしょうし
失敗したってもしょうがないしね
こちらの体の血管は派手に見えませんし
見えたって細いし だから向こうのせいだと言えないでしょうね
と言っても 私は 2  3回は刺して申し訳ないんです
それで冗談ちょっと冗談言って落ち着いてもらって
で 一発 だから あの これは患者さんに期待していてもダメでしょ
私みたいな変な変な人だったらね
下ネタを言うかもしれませんだけど
そうは言いませんから
やっぱり精神的な落ち着く何かを準備した方がいいでしょう
他は答えがないんです
はい ヒューマンスキルがね
ちょっと欠けちゃったために
他の 2つのスキルが抜群にあっても
職場を追い出されたり
左遷させられちゃったりっていう方々を見てきて
この 3つのスキルをどのようにバランスを取っていけばよろしいんでしょうか
結局は一つですよ  3つに分けてもヒューマンスキルでしょうに
すごい そういう世界で分節 3つある 4つあるって
私からもただ一つでしょうに
何コンセプチュアルあれ全部ヒューマンでしょうに
だからバランスとか何とか言われたっても
やっぱりまず人間であって
人間が落ち着いていると全部出ますよ
必要としている 2つも
全てヒューマンスキルのみなんです
だからそちらでヒューマンスキルというのは
ただ腕がいいか悪いかだけでしょ
だからそこはちょっとね
それはヒューマンスキルというよりはね
まあエクスペリエンスですからね
ヒューマンスキルっていうのは
こちらでちょこちょこ出たエクスペリエンスなんで
それまとめて全てヒューマンスキルなんです
そんなことでしょうね
私 メスはもう一度ちょっと忘れました
1番目がテクニカルです
テクニカル 2番目がヒューマンスキル
3番目がコンセプチュアル
コンセプチュアル だからもうテクニカルっていうのは人間考えることでしょうね
技術は で コンセプチュアルというか
コンセプトというのは
それ人間考えることじゃないでしょうか
それでどんな辺がヒューマンスキルになるのかっていうこと出てくるんですね
何考えてるんです？ヒューマンスキルから全部ヒューマンスキルですけどね
だからまあ それは動かせる
いわば労働者のことを考えているかもしれませんね
それで質問って何答えればいいんです？質問
この 3つの中で  そういう情報だけですけど
私から見ればね そういう風に分けてるんだと
それで仏教は何であっても悪口言いますから
それまとめて一つになっていた
だからあの私たちお寺でもかなり人々を扱ったりする世界だから
あの だからもう外国人に嫌われているかもしれませんだけど
いくら批判していても
お坊さんたちの力っていうのはね
そんな簡単に潰すことはできないんですね
というのは この我々は人扱いしてます
教会はもう全く知らない
我々は人は小奇策をする時もありますけど
この差別はないんですね
向こうはものすごくお坊さんのことはもう好きでたまらないだけ
そこがポイントなんです
だから我々は お前本当にアホやと言ったっても
向こうはもう喜んじゃって
結局は 時々難しい質問を問われる場合は
これはアホにしか頼めないんだけど
誰に頼もうかなというと
若者はこれ結局私でしょ？ってもう勝手に取ってるんです
私 私に言ってることでしょうと
で もうやってるんです
喜んで そこは見ても他の人々には真似できないんですよ
だから悪口言われるんですね
我々は国を支配しているんだとかね
国だけじゃなくて どこへ行っても支配できるんです
もうどうしようもないです
だからこの最終ポイントはね
やっぱり人間です 人間として扱って
人間に喜びを与えてあげて
幸福感を与えてあげて
特に喜びを与えなくちゃ
楽しませなくちゃいけないんですよ
脳がこの楽しみをね 感じると結構働くんです
脳の脳にある唯一なご褒美
それなんですよ 脳がずっと頑張ってるんですよ
そのために給料をくれと
脳にあげる給料はちょっとした喜びなんです
あ 気持ちいいな 楽しいって
それ与えてないでしょ
脳を給料払わずにタダ働きさせちゃって壊れますよ
だからスキル出してくれ
アイデア出してくれません
出ないんです だから十分敬意を払った方が
だからお釈迦様は この瞑想をどんどん立てていると
もう想像を絶する喜びが生まれますよと
やがて今 心の中で喜びを感じるだけでしょう
瞑想なんかすると もう全部全体的に喜びを感じて
さらに瞑想すると喜びに抑えられた状態になる
並大抵じゃないんです
それぐらいの脳に心にご褒美を与えているんだから
お釈迦様には過去でも何でもいくらでも見られるって
やってくれます だからこの俗世間は
でも簡単ですよね すごく楽しみ
喜び 楽しみ 充実感も楽しみなんですよ
充実感も楽しみ 喜び そこは何よりも大事やと
会社のなんだらかんだら分析じゃないんです
まずそれやと 楽しいかと
そうなってくると 頼まなくてもスキルは出すんですよ
アイデア出すんですよね
こうしましょうか？とかね
頼まなくてもいい 頼まなくてもいいんです
だから 仏教から答えるならば
そんな程度なんですよ
そちらに楽しみを入れてもらえば
4番目に 仕事の充実感というのは
これは関係ないと思っているんで
それが関係あるんです
それなんです 命は 誰が仕事のために生きてるんですか？畑やるために生まれたんですかね
逆でしょうに 畑を作ってご飯食べてすごい楽しい
だからやってるんだって
やらずにはいられないし
だったら種まきからもう何でもふざけて楽しくやっちゃえば
もう何の苦労もないでしょ
だから自分の畑を 土を掘ったりして
あまりにも楽しくなってくると
隣の人のところまでやってあげますからね
じゃあもうついでにあなたの畑もやりましたからねということになるんです
ご飯ありがとうございますで終わっちゃうんです
だから農家の人であっても
すごい楽しげにやると
明日種まきに行きますけど
おばあちゃんの畑もやりますかね
ついでにという感じでやりますよ
もう私たちはもう仕事をいかにサボるかっていうね
ことで頑張っているでしょ
かわいそうですよ 脳に栄養を与えてないんです
脳は激しい栄養失調で飢えている状態です
だから能力ないとか能力ないとかね
ふざけたことは言ってはならないんです
そういうことで話を終了しなきゃならないので
そのお釈迦の始まりです
はい 本当に長い時間大変ご苦労様でした
今日はやりすぎご苦労なさいまして
申し訳ございません じゃあどうもありがとうございました
[silence]